¿Por qué cuando te sacan una muela del
juicio también te dicen que te quites la
opuesta? ¿Ves esto? Esto no es solo una
muela normal, es una muela que ha bajado
tanto que ya está clavándose
prácticamente contra la encía de abajo.
Y no, no es porque el diente crezca para
siempre como mucha gente cree. Lo que
pasa es que los dientes necesitan un
contacto, necesitan un antagonista, algo
contra lo que morder. Cuando te quitan
una muela y dejas la opuesta sola, esa
muela pierde el freno natural que tenía
al masticar y poco a poco empieza a
desplazarse, a salir hacia abajo, a
extruirse. Y esto puede llegar a niveles
tan extremos como el que estáis viendo
aquí. El problema no es solo estético,
porque esa muela puede acabar golpeando
la encía contraria constantemente cada
vez que cierras la boca. Y esto puede
provocar dolor, inflamación e incluso
heridas crónicas. Pero además, al
moverse también cambia la forma en la
que te encajan los dientes y ahí
empiezan los problemas de mordida,
interferencias al cerrar, sobrecargas,
descargas oclusales, dolor muscular,
problemas en la articulación mandibular,
etcétera. Y encima, como esa muela queda
más expuesta y en una posición rara,
también se acumula más placa y más
restos de comida. El resultado, más
riesgo de caries, infección de encías y
problemas periodontales. Por eso muchas
veces cuando quitamos una muela del
juicio también valoramos quitar la
opuesta si ya no tiene función. Porque
dejar un diente completamente solo
dentro de la boca muchas veces acaba
generando problemas que tardan años en
aparecer, pero que luego son mucho más
difíciles de solucionar. Y esto es algo
que muchísima gente descubre cuando ya
es demasiado tarde.